we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day
I have not avoided all of the shrapnel
from the criticisms of how producer Pat
pronounces some words now I'm getting
hit with it take a listen to this
voicemail hey David its Julieta from
California one time to talk I was just
listening to your bonus show where you
were talking about
Pat's pronunciation of vowels but you
know David that you pronounce the word
can as Ken right just thought I'd point
that out I don't know if you've talked
about that before but yeah you you
pronounced it very strongly as Ken
interesting okay talk to you later guys
bye I never really thought about that so
I tend to say I can do that as opposed
to I can do that how do you pronounce it
I can do that I oh so you say the same
when as I put the name kem right I say
casi a n as if it's the name ke and
short for Kenneth I wonder what the
regionalization of that is the thing is
I'm willing to make some adjustments
with my pronunciation but I think part
of the reason why people like us so much
is that we're genuine okay don't try to
change too much to become some like
these local anchors you know so Europe
but there's then shouldn't you be
speaking with more of a Boston accent it
seems like you've eliminated it that
depends more so on the people who I'm
talking to
okay so yeah listen I've admitted
English is my second language I didn't
realize that the name Penelope was not
panel up when I saw it written until I
was probably halfway through high school
so I don't you know I don't know why
everybody's focusing on how I'm
pronouncing things all of a sudden I'm
sure there are plenty of native English
speakers who still don't realize that
it's not panel Oh another one I remember
is when I was a kid I would read Calvin
and Hobbes and there was a one comic
strip in it which if you've read have it
in Hobbes you probably know the comic
strip the word panache is there and I
genuinely had no idea how that word was
pronounced nevermind what it meant
because I was like six years old and I
think it was pretty far into middle
school or high school when I finally
nerd learned the term
and ash yeah I mean the Spelling's in
the English language are just very
strange especially if you're coming from
a language like Spanish where pretty
much everything is written how you would
pronounce it there are just so many
irregular things we have a silent e for
Christ's sake have you seen how the the
word D h OT i no GH OT i could be
pronounced fish based on certain english
pronunciation
I did not see because gh is sometimes
pronounced as an F like for example at
the end of the word tough I rather O is
sometimes pronounced as I and T I is
sometimes pronounced as as in transition
Wow so Ghoti it's a very interesting
thing if you google it Ghoti you'll see
it Ghoti according to English language
could be pronounced fish see we all know
about the things like pH makes the F
sound or silent e but those examples I
think that you have a case there I think
I do and I encourage people who look it
up it is compelling reading on the bonus
show today Congress and Trump have
agreed to allow the hunting of
hibernating bears and Wolf Cubs in a
Wolf Den the journalists who exposed
Trump's grab them by the you-know-what
video has won Apollo surprise we will
talk about the upcoming vacation for the
show a lot is happening on the bonus
show sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code I voted 17 and of
course keep the patreon donations
growing we are beyond 1200 at
patreon.com slash david pakman show